the bar just tanked indeed knight d2  whoa not a fan so b-a-b-a rook a8 we  tried to explain that apparently  computer strongly dislikes this although  it looks very normal because you  actually attack something  but the extra squares given for the rook  seemed to make a difference and after  knight to d2 yeah do you think just like  g3 just picks up material instantly  winning yeah  because like neither through checking at  four and  no defense against h3 i guess next move  right look here h3 picks up horsey  bet mark on it being higher in previous  years  my best guess would be 40 45 but i'm  i'm not sure it's just on field i'm sure  yeah could be could be figured out but  one third sounds low  18. i mean in this tournament i'm pretty  sure i'm correct and i'm pretty sure it  is it is like  almost exactly one-third but